y desviante que es la campeona de Roland
garros en un partido lleno de tensión y
de puntos de giro en un primer sed donde
las cosas parecían que iban aún en una
sola vía en una vía que llegaba hacia y
gas viantex Quien comenzó jugando un
tenis muy preciso y terminó ganando Esa
primera manga seis uno sin embargo a
pesar de que el segundo set había
comenzado un poco como la copia de lo
primero Carolina mufoba logró un break
bastante temprano en ese set Y a partir
de ese momento comenzó su recuperación
con la Checa jugando un magnífico tenis
en donde todo le salía mientras que se
veía hay que frustrada y cometiendo
muchísimos errores a no forzados de esta
manera a pesar de que fue una sed
bastante apretado fue la Checa quien se
quedó con la segunda manga siete cinco
primer set que pierde y gaseante que en
este torneo y primera vez que pierde un
set en una final de Grand lámpara poner
las cosas muchísimo más complicadas para
la polaca y todo parecía que iba a
continuar así digamos con la suerte
sonriéndole a
prácticamente perdida al comienzo de ese
tercer set sin embargo poco a poco ella
fue recuperándose también mostrando
también esa mentalidad de campeona que
tiene para llevar las cosas hasta un
cinco cuatro cuando ya le faltaba
poquito para quedarse con ese tercer set
y con la victoria pero era muy joven a
quien estaba al servicio y finalmente
Pues fue muy joven a quien con una doble
falta cuando ya iban 40 15 pues ha dado
no solamente el set sino la victoria a
la polaca que se convierte hoy a sus
veintidós años en la jugadora más joven
en ganar sus cuatro finales de granos
algo que nadie había hecho desde Serena
Williams entre 1999 y 2002